ketchup mustard ohh sausages bumpy  I can  denim straight boys Hey look at this  with no one yes we're chosen hey Brenda  you and me I'm so happy that God's put  our packages together because we belong  together like we were made for each  other get ready boy ah feels amazing oh  yes I ain't the first to enter eternity  the bleep starpoints our car Jesus [ __ ]  Oh Tommy skin keep peeling me [ __ ]  [ __ ]  children [ __ ] enchantress so you have  learned the terrible truth I gotta tell  everyone no one will believe you I have  to try everyone will die otherwise no  yeah that's a good point [ __ ] me right  [ __ ] [ __ ] run [ __ ] lives hey once you  see that [ __ ]  it'll [ __ ] you up  good luck have fun